ouais bien on baisse la lumière ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle bells ah bon alors
je vous faire virginie et coralie une
petite interview psy c'est tombé sur
vous voulez pas répondre coralie on va
voir ça sans génie comme la ligue
edouard baer cebrian à épandre abu sisi
ci est ce qu est ce que vous êtes parano
les filles
mouais faut il faut il faut il faut être
par le bas mais je vous êtes schizo way
ou pas tellement non bah non apparemment
non puisque il n'y a pas de différence
entre votre vie professionnelle et votre
vie privée vous dites que ça fait partie
de moi j'ai beaucoup de facettes
différentes mais ça te contacte ne
semble pas être facile parce que mes
facettes sans aucun problème très bien
qu elle est ce que vous êtes sado
vaguement quand même vous aimez bien
faire mal ouais j'aime bien et mazeaud
répondu en main sont pas trop mais par
contre ça nous et j'ai pratiqué pendant
que j'ai fait beaucoup plus jeune vous
avez fait la dominatrice
ouais et alors alors c'était rigolo mais
on s'en lasse ah oui on s'en lasse aussi
d'alors
vous êtes exhibo oui vous coralie on le
sait vous l'avez dit allez votre époque
petit quand vous l amour sur la scène de
la loco virginie est ce que vous êtes
exhibo non non de géronto pourquoi pas
le noir est gérante au noir
mais voilà à est ce que vous êtes pédo
plus j'aime plus les garçons que les
hommes en fait c'est un peu pédo je
reconnais cipres excuse enzo voilà non
non non non non non les doigts mais je
me dis les bois est ce que vous êtes
ayrault c'est quoi ouais pourquoi pas
ouais je vous ai de coco arrive moi j'ai
tout essayé sauf l'hérault en fait vous
êtes coco je vous êtes adamo non je
voudrais être adamou c'est bien beau
ben moi j'adore perso c'est la pire de
toutes c'est à bignan dernier vous êtes
adam en bon état c'est bizarre c'est le
vrai maître tombe la neige annonce que
je vous ai de disco venus pacifiquement
et si j'ai beaucoup bu pourquoi pas
bien on rallume on continue dans le sexe
et la défonce
mais cette voie dans un milieu
inattendue